welcome to this video plane she lost
scar from from Spain I'm Spain let's see
I had this request to play the Dutch
sometime but last time I tried I got
sort so destroyed oh it's a grandmaster
only now saw that does not have the name
in there so probably a secondary profile
or secondary handle 22 to play
anonymously I'm trying for a bit a bit
of a more fighting approach against this
opening the No d 5 is the most
interesting way to play this okay let's
let's change the central structure huh
with d5 now that looks that looks very
under bishes in a way but it's certainly
am certainly a healthy structure huh
okay
let me think about this for just a
moment somehow this does not seem right
to me what why this doing I can take
default play night f4 I know it's weird
but it's probably probably just good
right attacking g2d three of the queen
of course I must be a and must exhibit
some caution and now I had no I'm
winning immediately this is this is
winning a queen it's a typical tactic
this does not happen often against the
GM and needed to play the Queen
somewhere else where this bread is
protected threatening night h3 reason
winning the Queen enter and queen g2
made while what a disaster that's
probably record for quickest win against
the GM yeah here this this Queenie to
move looked innocent but I think it's
just a big mistake I mean white does not
have anything here anyway I can i but
IAM kind of cosplay something like this
where nothing much is happening but this
is a this is simply a mistake due to the
smooth he cannot play the intermediate
movement because i have a direct made
threat takes night and for him and this
is scarce is ugly where's where's he's
supposed to go i mean if he goes here
for example there's also queen g5 with
the maid it's very very quick business
he probably has to go here no not
probably he has to go there otherwise a
cheek and then i can take this with a
temple now he must he must try it to
play a position like that which is not
looking good but at least allows here
this is this allows form for practical
chance of certainly
maybe just 97 this is not as idea yeah
funny quick win but it shows that
sometimes you need to check out even
somewhat somewhat unconventional moves
like this just hacking away this is this
night with the fianchetto bishop because
there's this direct IDM okay thanks for
watching